back in 2007 unbeknownst to most
Americans Congress passed a law phasing
out regular incandescent light bulbs
President George W Bush signed the bill
and the phase-out starts next January
[Music]
like yesterday we rock the show I flip
the switch you rock the glow so far from
Vienna luminescence notoriously
incandescent from the same always see
movie Congress taking you away from me
new bulb costs like 10 times more need a
hazmat crew when they hits the floor and
the future can't wait to see what they
look like at my vanity ridiculous night
they took your friend try to black it
out for the plays again say the change
is what I need to make it the sound
Mennella from my easy-bake if anything
happens
[Music]
that's right this kind of hardwood unite
around Bob warms up like a half and now
watching us as we pray for you every day
we pray for you until the day we meet
again in the dark is where I'm reading
friend
[Music]
oh why
[Music]
copy government tell me what I could put
in my life right
[Music]